WARRANTS, THAT IS A -- THAT --
IT'S ON A LINE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
WE SHOULDN'T JUST BLOW TO THE
CRIME WAS COMMITTED HERE.
JOINING US ON THE PHONE, GEORGE
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR,
JONATHAN TURLEY WHO HAS BEEN
WATCHING THESE EVENTS UNFOLD.
YOUR REACTION TO THE FIRING OF
ANDREW McCABE, TWO DAYS BEFORE
HIS 50th BIRTHDAY WHERE HIS
PENSION WOULD HAVE KICKED IN.
PROFESSOR?
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED BY THE
DECISION.
SOME OF US SAID IT WOULD BE
LIKELY THAT HE WOULD BE FIRED.
THE REASON IS THAT THIS IS AN
EXCEEDINGLY RARE RECOMMENDATION
COMING FROM THE OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
IT'S VIRTUALLY UNHEARD OF FOR
SOMEONE THAT HELD THE POSITION
OF McCABE.
SO IT WAS VERY UNLIKELY IN MAY
VIEW THAT JEFF SESSIONS WOULD
NOT FOLLOW THAT CAREER ADVICE.
HE FOLLOWED THAT ADVICE IN HIS
OWN RECUSAL.
HE YIELDED TO CAREER OFFICERS
THAT HAD RECOMMENDED THAT
COURSE.
I'VE SAID BEFORE, I THOUGHT HE
WOULD DO WHAT HE DID TONIGHT.
WHAT IS A MORE DIFFICULT
QUESTION THAT WILL BE PRESENTED
FOR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
HOW THEY WILL GO FROM HERE.
BECAUSE THE SUGGESTION IS THAT
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND THAT
McCABE INTENTIONALLY MISLEAD
THEIR INVESTIGATORS.
THAT'S ALMOST INDISTINGUISHABLE
FROM WHAT THEY CHARGED MICHAEL
FLYNN WITH.
>> Laura: EXACTLY.
A GOOD POINT.
>> SO THE QUESTION ON THE TABLE
HERE IS ONE OF CONTINUITY.
FLYNN IS ACCUSED OF LYING ABOUT
NOT THE MEETING WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
HE APPARENTLY ADMITTED THAT.
BY TALKING ABOUT SANCTIONS.
THE MEETING WITH THE RUSSIANS
WAS NOT ILLEGAL.
IN THIS CASE, McCABE IS ACCUSED
OF MISLEADING INVESTIGATORS ON
SOMETHING THAT WAS A VIOLATION
OF FEDERAL RULES.
SO I THINK THE QUESTION WILL BE
RAISED IS, WELL, IS THIS SIMPLY
A MATTER OF A PENSION OR --
BECAUSE FOR FLYNN, IT WAS A
MATTER OF PRISON.
>> Laura: CAN'T BE.